Today we're doing the oldest number
system in the world:
Babylonian Cuneiform Numbers.
( Brady: Cu-ne-iform?)
- Yeah it's true, I thought it was
cuneiform too but then I went I spoke to
one of the curators of the cuneiform
collection at the british museum
and in this first sentence out his mouth
has said cu-ne-iform
so that's how one should say it.
So the first
writing system is cuneiform and it
evolved about three thousand years BC
between the Tigris and the Euphrates, the
kind of Sumerian civilisation.
And what it is it's bits of mud, you make
a mark
using a reed - although here I've got a
lollipop stick and I've got some potty
putty;
but it's essentially the same. Cuneis is
the Latin for wedge and it's all about
making
wedge marks. So when you see it written
down
you see with like little triangles and
lines but that's just because they're
trying to make it look like an actual 3d
wedge mark, but today
I'm going to be able to show you using
actual 3d wedge marks.
So the system of writing things down
emerge around about 3000 BC,
but I'm going to sort of speed forward
to about 2000 BC
when the number system was already kind
of in fully functioning order
and kind of worked, and pretty much the
oldest kind of mathematical tablets that
we have
are from that period. And it's- you call
that Babylon so it's the kind of
civilisation
that kind of came on after Suma. So how
do Babylonian
numbers work? Well I'm going to take
one of my tablets and- one thing which is
interesting,
all the tablets that were used to make
cuneiform on are really about this size.
So often you see them in photographs and
they kind of expanded and you think, well
maybe this tablet was this kind of
massive tablet like a kind of gravestone,
well no they're all just about this size
almost
like a- you know say half an iphone or
something.
If you go to the British museum where
they have well over a hundred thousand
of these tablets - they're more like this,
they're kind of squareish
and there's got all the writing on it
because,
how do you write it? You write it by
holding the tablet in one hand and
holding the reed in the other and then
making the marks.
It was used over a period of 3000 years,
so it's actually the writing system and
number system that have been used for the
longest period of time,
much more than the Latin alphabet or
Roman numerals
or Arabic numerals. So in terms of
say what you call civilisation, since the
early civilisations it's been used for
two-thirds really of human history.
(I wonder if ours will
ever overtake it or)
(something else will come along?)
(Or I wonder if ours will ever become the)
(title holder?)
What our Arabic numerals? Well you could
argue that hexadecimal or even base
two has really overtaken it because we
live in a world of computers and that's
how computers work.
The number system uses only two types of
wedge.
1 is this - that's 1.
2 is another one, 3
that's three. 4, 5,
6, 7, 8, 9.
So 1 to 9 you're just adding- it's
quite like
Roman numerals but you're just keeping
on adding the same digits.
When you get to ten you use- I'm
going to turn this over-
and you use the other sort of horizontal
and use that, so that's 10.
And you want to
carry on counting you'd go
back to the vertical...12, 13, 14, 15,
16, 17, 18, 19;
and 20 would be
Sorry whoops
- (Two horizontals?)
Two horizontals. So keep on going
they go to
30,
40, 50;
51, 52, 53,
54, 55, 56, 57, 58, 59 -
and can you guess what 60 is?
- (Well I)
(would have thought it would be)
(six horizontals?)
- You fell into my trap.
You fell into my trap! This...
is 60. Because you're starting
off with a system
which is adding new symbols, which is
just like Roman,
but it also had a positional element. And
when you get to 60
you move along. So this should be a zero
here but the problem with the
Babylonians, they didn't have a symbol
for zero.
Later on they invented a kind of symbol
for zero,
but actually they never used it in a
case like this;
so that is 60. 61 is this,
62, 63 - actually
that's a better 63 - 64, 65, 66,
67, 68, 69, and 70.
I mean yeah 70 would be
one 60 and
a 10. It's called a sexagesimal system,
i.e. base 60. You've got this column that
counts up to 60
and then this one here, whatever you have
in there you multiply by 60.
So actually just say you wanted to go
further on, that number there
is 3661.
(If you want to do 3671)
(you'd put like a- )
- Yeah that would have
- (A 10 in there?)
- 10 would go here. But if
you wanted to put a 10 here
that would mean you have to times 60 by
11, which is 660,
so that would be 3600 plus 660
plus 11.
- (How would you write)
(3601? Do you have to have like a)
(space)
(in that column?)
- Yes, so that- the
Babylonians
required a symbol for zero for when
there was nothing in that column.
And eventually they started to use
two diagonals basically like that, two
diagonals;
that would be 3601 with the two
diagonals
to indicate nothing in the middle. This
only occurred in later
Babylonian mathematical texts and also
they never used it
at either side, so you couldn't tell the
difference between
sort of 110 and 1100
for example; and just 11.
But they did use it as a marker to
separate
middle columns. So you've got this really
interesting combination of a positional
system
and a sort of non-positional system. And
you might think, well isn't that
complicated?
It might look complicated, actually
for doing maths it's really good and
it's much much better than the
Roman system.
With the Roman system, you get up to M,
that's a thousand. And then if you want
to get more than a thousand you just
keep on doing Ms, Ms forever.
Whereas here if you want to get bigger
you just need to go to one new column
and then you get the next multiple of 60
up. So you can actually get
very quickly to really high numbers; but
also you can go the other way,
like the decimal point. If you were to
put a 1 here
that would be 160. And if
you were to put a 1
next to that that would be one 3600th.
It's very good at getting big numbers,
very good at dividing into small numbers,
much better; because the Romans they use
kind of fractions, it's really
complicated
and difficult to do whereas this you
could do very well.
And it is no coincidence the Babylonians
were the best astronomers of their age
by far
and one of the reasons is that they had
a much much better number system they
could use to do it. And in fact they were
so good
that the real- you know, you might have
thought well why 60?
60 sounds familiar. The reason why - we
still use base 60 when talking about the
time, so 60 seconds in a minute,
60 minutes in an hour, is that 60 was
the number chosen as the base by the
Babylonians right at the beginning.
And it's because of all their kind of
stargazing etc that that- even though the
Greeks had a different number
system than the
Romans did,
they just kept the base 60 when talking
about time.
(And why did the Babylonians choose 60?)
Well this is really interesting and it's
probably one of the biggest questions in
ancient mathematics,
no one knows. There are two possible
explanations; one,
it could be that- just say you're
approximating a circle,
you might want to put a hexagon in it.
A hexagon is actually
six triangles with 60
degrees, so already -
just say you want to divide each sixth
into ten -
then you get sixty. So that's one reason
they think-
- (But why divide it into ten?)
(Are we coming back to fingers now?)
Yes because the thing that's most
natural to do,
in the way to count, and there was a base
10 system
embedded in their base 60 system, because
we get
just the horizontal lines until we get
to 10 when we come to this other
symbol, is that here we've got the sixes;
the most
natural thing to divide a circle to is
into sixths. You know, we got to 360
degrees,
so that's interesting already, we've kept
that 360 degrees.
Divided into six so that each one is 60
degrees then maybe it's easier just to
then use your hands and divide that
into 10. The other reason why 60
is really good
is that 60 is a very divisible number.
The numbers that divide into 60 are 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6,
10, 12, 20, 30 and then 60.
That's really good for doing arithmetic
in your head and also
for just dividing stuff up; it's like-
it's like really really useful.
So that- it could be that, it could be a
mixture of both. I mean some people think
that;
60 is also 5 times 12 they could have
been a
base 5 number system, because
ten, that's one system; they are also base
side number systems with the five
figures on our hand,
and they could have been a base 12.
12 is also a very divisible number.
No one quite knows. But it's interesting
that the very oldest type of number
is still present with us every day.
A bit more from this interview can be
found on our second channel,
Numberphile2, and for lots more of this
type of stuff why not check out Alex
Bellos'
'The Language Lovers' Puzzle Book'. There
are links in the video description.
Thanks also to our Numberphile patrons,
including those
whose names you're seeing on the screen
at the moment.
...say that the
digit can be used, kind of all singing or
dancing
number digit just like all the others,
that was the Indians.
It was moving it from a kind of
placeholder to realising that no no it
can actually behave really really well.
And even when it appeared in India it
took centuries
for people to actually begin to play
around with it and realise
that you know-